my hey are you gaining weight bro you
looking like you know what I'm saying
you might be hitting that that grow man
weight bruh so if you listening I told
you yeah you looking like a grown-up now
well the first time I met you was in the
middle of the pandemic and you guys had
like 75 guys at my studio recording and
it was just terribly responsible during
covet but you're like yeah you got the
man wait on bro you look like a grown
ass man now it's hard yeah uh hey but yo
I gotta say me and my boy s dot were
just talking about it you and the the
controversy tape is one of my favorite
projects of the year
y'all delivered on that [__] for sure
and I appreciate you saying that I think
you DM me and said that and I appreciate
it because I know how like you you
critical like when it comes to projects
and stuff for sure like you even said
that Drake's not up there with your
favorite projects like like you said he
ain't got like no Holy Grail like like
no you're right I did say that I pay
attention to what you say like hey man
well I'm just super proud of you man
because
you're that guy right now in Detroit
brother you said one of them guys period
appreciate you you do get snubbed on
that freshman cover
should have been on there let's just say
it here crazy snub
I ain't gonna say that next year maybe
next year maybe but next year by then
it'll be too late yeah I understand them
though well they did just interview you
so you have to be nice yeah it's the
last post I just saw on your IG
yo um how are we feeling about your team
making Monty Williams the richest coach
ever
my former coach
oh no he just got fired he did because
two years in a row game sevens the sun's
got embarrassed and eliminated yeah I'm
all for it if he's gonna help us he's
going to build culture and help the
young guys yeah I want wins though yeah
yeah we need wins like that you got Cade
who's got to stay healthy guys Ivy's a
beast beast uh what's the big dude named
is it Duren Jay Lindor and then James
wiseman's on the [__] Pistons which
is random it's random but I feel like if
you get healthy you can grab a lot of
boards and block a lot of shots Sadiq
Bay got traded to the Hawks
um I don't know who else is on the
Pistons
I think Isaiah Stewart is a great
Stewart guy oh Isaiah Stewart that's the
guy who who threw the fade with the
LeBron yeah I think he's a great glue
guy
um he's kind of like a big Pat Bev I
want to see who who would get with the
number I think we got number five pick I
was really I was truly rooting for the
Pistons
yeah that would have been crazy I would
have got season tickets or Sundays we
got to pick
I feel like two or three years in a row
y'all kind of like y'all you guys got
Kade but then was it last year who y'all
you guys had I Ivy yeah you guys drafted
two players on the show I'd be in Durham
right yeah I think I think Ivy and
Darren and K was some great pickups um I
like how
um ivy can score the ball from um every
level basically and I like um I like
Jalen um during I like his
um aggression like he he 18 years old
attacking the course like Dennis rod
have you performed at a Pistons game yet
nope I put the Hydra I think I did the
introduction before nice
you know what I find to be [__] is
if you go to the Little Caesars Arena
they don't have five dollar Little
Caesars pizza I've heard no it's more
than that it's very disappointing
imagine you go to a game by the way it's
a piston game so the tickets are cheap
probably you're probably we've been eat
good tonight we're about to get us a
five dollar pizza at the Little Caesars
Arena what but when you get floor seats
you can go get free pieces you do yeah
free Little Caesars Pizzas very it's
like free 7-Eleven coffee it's like yeah
thanks you know it was kind of free
anyway yeah anyway but no I feel like
you've been on your [__] you obviously
just dropped the deluxe to your project
that you dropped in December
um
tell me about the bidding war that you
went through before you landed with
Interscope
oh it was a crazy being aware before I
got within the scope guessing uh
I had so many people I had people trying
to back door people I ain't even know
like like you know you know you don't
know your worth like with when it comes
to like music until you get like into
music business right and then it just
helped me know my worth it was just a
crazy being where it went from one
number to another number with
um what certain circumstances then they
they get took out of like the contracts
and all that they changed so yeah it's
almost like your leverage was going up
probably in the middle of all that in
the middle of it hey we might have
talked a month ago but the shit's gotta
look you got to take this out you gotta
take this out like like I I had talked
to giving it
um they was like I was damn near signed
right and then the lawyer had didn't
send a contract like kept playing on
sitting in the contract and they are
almost out with somebody else who'd you
almost signed with oh
man where'd you find it I forgot where
did I find it but he was he signed young
boy forgot what he was at Columbia he
went somewhere else
um but I almost signed with a couple of
people Capital was on me Atlantic was on
me and I had United Masters on me United
Masters I heard it is uh drop they got a
big X the plug right now yeah they had
chocolate
I had a lot of people any rapper Traders
on you like like I feel like CMG is like
the type of thing where Yo Gotti would
just bring you like a like 500 000 in
cash and be like here you go yeah but
you know it's it's all type of politics
that go in today right right right
because yeah yeah yeah I forgot who else
is yeah I for sure speaking of